[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute
guten abend zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem sonntag an meiner seite ist für
den sport katja stresow guten abend wer
regiert künftig deutschland das bleibt
auch heute eine zentrale frage
politik auf partnersuche spd und union
werben um mögliche koalitionsbeschlüsse
appell zur deutschen einheit bei den
feierlichkeiten zum dritten oktober
mahnt merkel nicht zu leichtfertig mit
demokratie umzugehen
infekte auf dem vormarsch auffallend
viele kinder leiden an
atemwegserkrankungen eine folge der
korona maßnahmen
es ist eine art speeddating der parteien
nach dem grüne und fdp sich schon in den
vergangenen tagen beschnuppert haben
steigen heute union und spd ein in die
suche nach passenden regierungspartnern
um 15 uhr 30 trafen sich die
verhandlungsteams von spd und fdp seit
einer stunde sitzen spd und grüne
zusammen parallel union und fdp über die
atmosphäre und erste annäherungen
berichtet britta spiekermann
der vizekanzler der noch amtierenden
großen koalition der gerne kanzler eine
ampel regierung werden würde olaf scholz
nimmt den weg durch die tiefgarage spd
und fdp sondieren sozialdemokraten und
liberale keineswegs natürliche
verbündete vertraulichkeit haben sich
alle parteien auf die fahnen geschrieben
gemeinsam ohne kamera spricht nicht
alleine vor dem
wie weit links wollen und werden die
liberalen ging keine steuererhöhungen
kein aufweichen der schuldenbremse so
ihre bedingungen schwere brocken für die
spd nach den gesprächen zeigt sich die
spd ein wenig optimistischer als die fdp
das waren sehr konstruktive gespräche
sehr stark in der sache orientiert wir
sind uns dass es deutlich geworden
bewusst dass es große herausforderungen
gibt die vor diesem land liegen nach 16
jahren merkel klar ist dass es klappen
gibt aber klar ist auch dass wir
entschlossen sind eine
reform regierung zu bilden die unser
land nach vorne bringt verschwiegenheit
vereinbart über konkretes es geht zu wie
im taubenschlag an diesem sonntag auch
ein treffen von spd und grünen sowie am
abend gespräche zwischen fdp und union
der angeschlagene parteivorsitzende
laschet sucht nach geschlossenheit in
den eigenen reihen ampel oder jamaika es
ist der tag der sondierungen hinter
geschlossenen türen
fragen wir theo koll zum auftakt der
sondierungen heute welche konstellation
hat derzeit die besten chancen
also die ampel hat aktuell klar die
besseren chancen auch wenn der ton eben
nach dem ersten spd fdp treffen zwar
konstruktiv aber erkennbar nüchtern war
christian lindner und die fdp wollen
weiterhin am liebsten eine jamaika
regierung bilden aber sie schauen
täglich ratlose auf den zustand der
union und die massive innerparteiliche
kritik an armin laschet die union müsse
klären sagte er ob sie wirklich eine
regierung führen will für laschet gilt
ja mittlerweile kanzler oder ku was
wiederum für linden ein problem ist denn
das schwächt seine verhandlungsposition
bei der spd je unwahrscheinlicher
jamaika wird desto weniger
verhandlungsmasse hat die fdp in eine
ampel und bewertungen der bilateralen
gespräche wird es erst geben wenn alle
mit allen geredet hat die einschätzung
von theo koll vielen dank
heute ist feiertag der tag der deutschen
einheit seit 31 jahren sind ost und west
wieder vereint für die bundeskanzlerin
war es ihre letzte einheitsrede beim
zentralen festakt in sachsen-anhalt in
halle an der saale merkel nutzte sie für
persönliche worte und für einen appell
es gelte der farm und radikalisierung
innerhalb der gesellschaft
entgegenzutreten luisa huber berichtete
wegen chor ohne auch in diesem jahr kein
großes bürgerfest und doch hat halle es
geschafft die menschen an diesem
feiertag zusammenzubringen zum beispiel
auf dem markt dort erinnerte eine
ausstellung an die gemeinsamen jahre es
ist vieles gelungen es ist viel im
aufbau gelungen an der infrastruktur das
war ja doch sehr marode bei uns wir
müssen leider noch so sehen dass wir
jetzt für 31 jahre deutsche einheit
haben aber ja zum beispiel die renten in
ost und west immer noch nicht gleich
sind man sollte nicht mehr vergleichen
zwischen ost und west es gibt
unterschiede sind immer noch da und die
wird auch in zukunft geben aber im
endeffekt sind wir ein land der
offizielle festakt fand in der händel
halle statt
ministerpräsident und gastgeber reiner
haseloff mahnte an dass die einheit
mental wie strukturell noch nicht
vollendet sei
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel hielt eine
sehr persönliche rede als bürgerin aus
ostdeutschland berichtete sie von
momenten in denen ihre herkunft pauschal
als ballast wahrgenommen wurde
das ist die lehre aus 31 jahren
deutscher eine wir brauchen respekt vor
den jeweiligen biografien und
erfahrungen und auch vor der demokratie
die so mahnte merkel sei aktuell in
gefahr und müsse entschieden verteidigt
werden die demokratie sei ein hohes gut
für dass die ddr bürger auf die straße
gegangen waren was demokratie und
vielfalt ausmachen konnten bürger
unterdessen in der innenstadt erleben
alle 16 bundesländer und die
verfassungsorgane waren ebenfalls mit
ausstellungen vertreten
ganz bewusst wird am tag der deutschen
einheit auch der tag der offenen moschee
gefeiert als ein zeichen der
zugehörigkeit wie islam verbände betonen
es gehe auch um den abbau von ängsten
und vorurteilen
zum 25 mal öffneten bundesweit viele
gotteshäuser ihre türen minute nein zu
gesprächen führungen und workshops
zehntausende interessierte kamen zu den
rund 1.000 teilnehmenden
moscheegemeinden
mehr als 300 teils hochrangige politiker
sowie zahlreiche prominente aus der
ganzen welt sollen ihr geld in
steueroasen untergebracht haben das
ergibt sich aus einem vor einer halben
stunde veröffentlichten gigantischen
datenleck enthüllt von einem team aus
600 journalisten in 117 ländern genannt
werden unter anderem der könig von
jordanien der ukrainische präsident
zielinski der tschechische
regierungschef barbisch sowie der
ehemalige britische premier blair ganz
anderes thema jetzt viel mehr kinder als
sonst leiden gerade unter
atemwegserkrankungen wie husten oder
schnupfen vor einem jahr war das noch
ganz anders denn die korona maßnahmen
händen nicht nur das kona virus sondern
auch andere infektionen nachteil kinder
haben zu wenig immunabwehr aufgebaut das
rächt sich jetzt voll check
lehre kitas hochgestellte stühle kein
kontakt mit anderen kindern das sind
bilder aus der dritten corona welle das
geschieht zum schutz von kindern und
erziehern dieser schutz führte aber auch
dazu dass jetzt verstärkt kinder unter
sechs jahren unter atemwegsinfekten
leiden kinderärzte sind sie sicher sie
holen die schnupfen erkrankungen nach
die sie vergangenes jahr nicht bekommen
haben das robert-koch-institut hat vor
allem das respiratorische sind sozial
virus im visier ein infekt der atemwege
die krankenhauseinweisungen bei kindern
im alter von 1 bis 4 sind stark
gestiegen vor der pandemie wurden im
september rund 60 bis 70 kinder mit
schweren atemwegsinfektionen
eingeliefert jetzt sind es doppelt so
viele tendenz steigend
das erwarten dann wird sich die
situation so schwer verschärfen dass wir
unsere kinder unsere wirklich kranken
kinder auf den stationen der kliniken
nicht mehr unterbringen hier muss
dringend etwas getan werden was
allerdings sehr sehr schwierig ist weil
eben
kompetente pflegerinnen und pfleger
nicht einfach so vom himmel fallen der
verband der kinder und jugendärzte
fordert dass sich jetzt möglichst viele
an den grippe impfung beteiligen
der beste schutz für die kinder ist die
impfung der erwachsenen und zwar der
erwachsenen die viel mit den kindern zu
tun haben das sind vor allen dingen die
lehrer und erzieher und das andere
schulpersonal aber natürlich auch die
eltern viele eltern werden bis zum
winter wohl ein problem mehr bekommen
denn wer seine kinder mit
erkältungssymptomen in kita oder schule
schickt riskiert auch immer den verdacht
einer corona infektion
und jetzt der sport katja heute ist ein
großer tag für das deutsche tischtennis
das kann man so sagen vor wenigen
minuten haben die männer bei der team em
in rumänien die goldmedaille geholt um
was die können konnten die frauen schon
am nachmittag sie gewannen völlig
verdient das finale gegen den gastgeber
mit 3 zu 1 vielmehr glückseligkeit geht
nicht die deutschen frauen feiern den
überraschungserfolg gegen die
titelverteidigerinnen ausgiebig ein
schlüssel zum sieg die starke leistung
von sabine winter gegen die ehemalige
einzel-europameisterin elizabeta samara
sie holt den zweiten punkt für
deutschland
nach der niederlage von chantal mantz
hat nina mittel haben die chance das
spiel zu entscheiden ebenfalls gegen
samara und sie zeigt wie schon im
halbfinale eine fantastische leistung
die 24 jährige gewinnt in diesem finale
auch ihr zweites einzel damit sieht
deutschland 3 1 und holt den
europameistertitel
zum fußball das erste sonntagsspiel in
der bundesliga zwischen mainz und union
berlin endete 1 2 taiwo abo nie dabei
mit dem tore-doppelpack für die berliner
der rad klassiker paris roubaix berühmt
und gefürchtet für seine
kopfsteinpflaster heute kamen noch
dauerregen wind und schlamm dazu so
nicole rallye aus italien meisterte das
wie auch immer am besten und gewann nach
2 157 kilometern
es sind zweifellos tränen der freude die
der italiener so nicole valley nach
einem dramatischen schlussspurt als
sieger im ziel vergiesst zuvor hatte der
radsport klassiker perry robe die
vertrauten spektakulären stürze
geliefert die dieses radrennen seit
jahrzehnten schon immer wieder neu
infrage stellen gut 17 kilometer vor dem
ziel konnten sich drei fahrer absetzen
im schlussspurt an hatte kolbe rallye
die meisten reserven und gewann vor dem
belgier florian frisch und den
niederländer mathieu van de pol
bester deutscher jonas rutsch auf platz
11 name gott sei dank ein programm heute
fühlt sich plötzlich so sauber stimmt
das wetter ist herbstlich vom
schwarzwald bis zur oder meist dichte
wolken zeitweise regen sonst trocken und
vor allem im nordwesten längerer
sonnenschein höchstwerte 13 bis 20 grad
und auch die nächsten tage bleiben sehr
wechselhaft bei ähnlichen temperaturen
das heute journal mit marietta slomka um
viertel vor zehn wir wünschen ihnen
einen guten start in die neue woche
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sind und sind jetzt gespannt was theo
koll in berlin direkt zu sagen hat
herzlichen dank barbara hahlweg zur
stunde also sitzen sie zusammen laschet
und lindner hatten gemeinsam von jamaika
geträumt aber laschet wird parteiintern
und öffentlich immer mehr die
legitimation entzogen wir sprechen
gleich mit dem chef der jungen union
generation und damit herzlich willkommen
zu berlin direkt